في الثقافه اليابانيه للنساء نصيب الاسد
فيما يتعلق بامور البحر والصيد والغطس
نساء في الستين والسبعين من اعمارهم يقضين
معظم وقتهن في قاع البحر بحثا عن كنزه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
في هذا الارخبيل الياباني هناك اكثر من
4000 جزيره
يعيش سكان هنا في علاقه وثيقه مع عالم
البحار
لكن ما يميز هذا المجتمع تخصص النساء في
صيد الاسماك والمحار والقواقع منذ مئات
السنين
كينيا واحده من اخر السيدات التقليديه
الخبيرات ببواطن البحر ومحتوياته تعيش في
احدى الجزر جنوب مدينه نار اليابانيه
البحر بالنسبه لها حكايه قديمه متجدده
تعيشها وترويها كل يوم
[موسيقى]
مرتين في اليوم وهذا الصيد مقيد بقواعد
لحمايه البيئه
حيث يقتصر وقت الصيد على 70 دقيقه
وبمجرد اعطاء اشاره البدء ينطلق السباق من
اجل صيد المحار والاخطبوط وقنافذ البحر
وتقوم النساء بما مجموعهم 100 غطسه في
اليوم
[تصفيق]
على الرغم من ممارسه الصيد من قبل غالبيه
النساء هنا الى ان بعض الرجال يمارسون هذا
النشاط لتغطيه نفقاتهم لكن يظل تواجدهم في
هذا المجال استثنائي
هذه المراه التي يقترب عمرها من ثمانيه
عقود ما زالت قادره على ركوب الامواج
وتحمل مخاطر البحر والغطس باتجاه القاع
لغرض الصيد
هذه المهمه البحريه النسائيه الفريده
تتورثها السيدات هنا منذ عقود البحر
منزلهن وهن اخر ممثلات لتلك التقاليد
وبوفاتهم ربما تنتهي هذه الطقوس الى الابد
[موسيقى]